bonjour riadh sidaoui merci de répondre
à nos questions ce matin sur arte france
le premier ministre algérien abdelaziz
djerrad a déjà voté mais beaucoup
prédisent une faible abstention à quoi
s'attendre quarante et cinquante pour
sow d'ailleurs les spectateurs pour la
constitution c'était au tour de val
thorens morceau la même chose pour les
élections présidentielles donc ici la
transparence des chiffres ça veut dire
on va pas avoir 90 % comme les
dictatures arabes étaient toujours donc
on va attendre ça mais il faut le
rappeler aussi qu'il ya une révolution
en 2019
la preuve motif des cas échéant son
cinquième mandat
ces deux premiers ministres armand
teillard à voir mais l'excellent sont en
prison pour corruption
la même chose pour les plus grandes
sommes aux affaires en algérie alors tu
es allé à des dom event à côte et aussi
aussi ne pas trop d r d qui armés de
yahia aussi même vous receviez un fallen
qui seront présents quelques cadres qui
sont en dix ans donc mais cette cette
révolution n'a pas satisfait tout le
monde
il faut le savoir ne pas satisfait tout
le monde n'y a pas eu la langue magique
qui a résolu tous les problèmes socio
économiques parce qu'ils sont assez
assez profond et sow ils sont aussi
d'origine lointaine qui sont accumulés
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est sur les
premières élections après la révolution
de 2019 et il y à un deuxième miracle
mais qui n'est pas comme le premier est
là pour vous mais pour 13 millions en
janvier qui sont descendus dans la rue
et qui étaient accompagnés par l'armée
parce qu'il ya une opposition entre le
peuple et l'armée qui ont réussi à
chasser bouteflika et savants du pouvoir
il ya une révolution certes mais qui n'a
pas satisfait tout le monde
évidemment la région de kabylie soit ce
soit la grande kabylie à tizi ouzou la
petite kabylie à bejaia ça va ça va
continuer ça va continuer le taux
d'abstention ça va continuer cette
rupture et ça ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
attention record qui va continuer comme
vous dites quid de la légitimité de ces
élections
l'absent l'abstention moi je suis en
suisse
une fois là et moi que 30 % de
participants autour de participants le
taux de participation a été moi que 3 %
c'est un phénomène mondial
il ya certes surtout les jeunes ne
sommes pas impliqués dans la politique
et il ils ne sont pas enthousiastes dans
les élections y compris en europe en
occident on a mené des analyses
comparatives qui montre bien que le taux
de 90% ça n'existe que dans les
dictatures mais évidemment il faut des
structures il faut des structures et
cette fois ci aussi on peut avoir une
grande surprise
d'habitude traditionnellement les trois
premiers partis gagnants sont toujours
le premier c'est le fln front de
libération nationale qui jouit de son
capital symbolique historique
deuxièmement le rnd affirme son patron
son exploit me dois y aller en prison
3 une fois troisièmement le mouvement
islamiste hamas mais aussi cette fois ci
a must est éclatée en deux ça veut dire
toi même ya trois formations islamistes
y participent dans ces élections
la surprise pourrait venir des listes
indépendant parce que les listes
indépendantes représente plus les jeunes
la jeunesse algérienne dans les listes
indépendantes on peut avoir une bonne
surprise pour la première fois c'est que
les indépendants les listes
indépendantes et gagner c'est à dire
qu'il y aurait un nouveau chapitre qui
s'ouvrirait en algérie si des
indépendants venait à remporter ces
élections législatives puis j'en profite
pour rappeler un com qui a eu des
figures indus
irak et de l'opposition qui ont été
arrêtés jeudi elles ont été libérées
cette nuit quelques messages sans voix
aux algériens c'est un message
d'ouverture politique que c'était bien
expliqué le président avait établi que
ce soit dans son interview avec le
magazine français le point où son
interview avec la chaîne arabe al jazira
donc si nos vertus politiques pour
abaisser la tension est pour dans mes
chances aux ir mais surtout à cette
jeunesse cette jeunesse
n'oublions pas aussi lire notre zoom est
ce logique et qui est copiée par harry
le phénomène biologique et politique et
le tribalisme en algérie le tribalisme
c'est la gauche il ya ça veut dire des
régions des rimes gyan qui votent pour
leurs mets aux enfants parfois leur
idéologie ou pour leur parti politique
mais juste pour leurs enfants
donc le tribalisme aussi jouer un rôle
sociologique surtout dans les villages
et dans les doigts et à la campagne et
qu'elle regarde la communauté
internationale sur ce scrutin notamment
de la france par exemple les médias
français sont généralement agressif je
vais imprimer vis-à-vis de l'algérie il
y à l'héritage colonial évidemment les
blessures de de la guerre de
l'indépendance de 1954 jusqu'à 1962
existe toujours ses blessures et les
archives de la cotisation et donc les
algériens ne pas vous en confiance dans
ce que les médias français disent à
propos de leurs actes surtout aussi on a
vu que les médias français évidemment à
l'exception de votre chaîne arte france
n'était pas enthousiaste à fleur de peau
vrille heures les manifestations du
gilet jaune ou comment la police
française a traité les gilets jaunes
mais si on compare avec comment la
police algérienne a traité les
manifestations on voit quand même une
différence
merten france qui couvre donc ces
élections législatives avec sur place
hassen chébili merci riadh sidaoui
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes politologue et
directeur du quart ap le centre arabe de
recherche et d'analysé politique et
sociale